ich habe mir selbst eine challenge
gestellt wie viele kekse schaffe ich mit
einem kilogramm also einer packung mehl
das ergebnis seht ihr am ende des videos
ich verrate euch nur so viel es sind
mehr als ihr wahrscheinlich gerade alle
vermutet fang nummer an
[Musik]
ich schreibe euch natürlich wie immer
alle ganz genauen mengenangaben hier
unten in die video beschreibung und ich
starte jetzt hier mit butter ihr könnt
auch margarine nehmen wir nehmen möchte
und die sollte wirklich zimmer warm sein
also gut eine stunde vorher aus dem
kühlschrank nehmen und dann geht das
jetzt hier in die rührschüssel in einer
küchenmaschine ihr dürft ihr natürlich
auch andere gerät benutzen da fahren
immer noch ganz viele nach dauert dann
halt wirklich nur zwei minuten länger
und da gebe ich dann noch zucker mit
dazu vanille extrakt und gleich nochmal
richtig ordentliche prise salz denn die
hebt noch mal den süßen geschmack
[Musik]
ich habe die butter zucker massiert vier
minuten lang schön gemixt auf fast
maximaler geschwindigkeit und jetzt ist
auch richtig schön hell cremig geworden
und da geben wir jetzt die eier nach und
nach rein also ich lag da wirklich eins
rein für das bis es sich verbindet und
20 sekunden ungefähr und gibt dann die
nächsten dazu und sobald das verrät ist
kommt auch schon die packung mit rein
[Musik]
der teig ist fertig der ist sehr weich
der klebt aber auch gar nicht an der
oberfläche habe ich mein ganzes mehr
verbraucht ja das kenne ich jetzt ja
auch noch ein denn der darf ruhig noch
so ein bisschen was ihr habt aber
natürlich auch je nachdem wie groß die
eier sind die möglichkeit mit ein
bisschen milch nach zu helfen falls ihr
merkt er ist zu trocken weil wenn er zum
beispiel kleine eier verwendet dann
könnt ihr noch so ein esslöffel milch
dazugeben bei mir war das jetzt aber
überhaupt nicht nötig ich mache jetzt so
dass die riesen teig ein hand in der
hälfte durch teile damit es einmal
besser verstauen kann im kühlschrank und
dann schön flach andrücken in
frischhaltefolie wickeln und dann je
nach dem ich alter kühlschrank
eingestellt ist so ein bis zwei stunden
noch mal richtig schön durch kühlen
lassen
[Musik]
so wir starten jetzt mal mit etwas
zitrone ich habe jetzt hier meinen
großen tag einmal in der hand ich werde
das jetzt einfach so machen dass ich mir
nur ein drittel davon nehme den rest
könnt ihr dann einfach wer den
kühlschrank tun und der mit
zitronengeschmack bekommt entweder
gleich
zitronenschalen abrieb reingehen das
funktioniert nur mit ungespritzten
zitronen also nur mit die bio zitronen
ich habe leider keine bio zitronen da wo
ich immer welche da hab aber ihr könnt
alternativ auch zitronen passte nehmen
verlegen ich euch gerne wird ziemlich
bei mir im shop oder halt wie gesagt
einfach den schalen abrieb da jetzt
gleich mit einem kneten
[Musik]
sobald ihr die zitronen passt so gut
eingearbeitet habe lasst euch da aber
auch nicht zu viel zeit denn die hand
wärme tut dem teig jetzt nicht so gut
könnt ihr das ganze auch schon abstechen
trauben groß würde ich jetzt mal sagen
also ganz so ungefähr und dann einfach
die kugeln direkt auf das mit backpapier
ausgelegtes backblech geben ich mache da
nämlich gleich noch so eine kleine mulde
rein und dann fühlen wir lemon curt
reine schmeckt so gut und das dürfte
tatsächlich auch mit button
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die limit plätzchen werden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
und unterhitze für zehn bis zwölf
minuten gebacken sie dürfen auch noch
ein bisschen hell bleiben damit sie
nicht zu trocken werden
[Musik]
und wir machen direkt weiter keine zeit
verschwenden hier wir machen weiter mit
marzipan kipferl und da nehme ich mir
jetzt wieder den teig aus dem
kühlschrank dann nehme ich mir wieder an
dritte weg und dann einfach
marzipanrohmasse dazu raspeln ich habe
es so gemacht dass ich die
marzipanrohmasse gerade nochmal in den
kühlschrank getan habe ich glaube dass
sie sich dann einfach besser raspeln
lässt
[Musik]
der richtig gut ihr müsst auch mal euren
zeigen welche leute nicht komplett nach
marzipan und jetzt einmal einen ganz
langen strang formen ich kann das auch
einmal halbieren bis zu lang und dann
nehmt euch einfach eine tankkarte oder
alternativ ein messer und sticht euch
schonmal immer gleichmäßig große teile
ab und dann einfacher form einfach
kipferl form mit backpapier ausgelegtes
backblech natürlich widerlegen und
anschließend wenn sie gebacken und ich
trug sie später noch in kuvertüre
[Musik]
die marzipan kipferl müssen jetzt noch
mal kurz in den kühlschrank denn der
teig ist schon ziemlich weich geworden
durch das ganze kneten natürlich das
ganze rollen und damit sie nicht
verlaufen einmal ganz kurz kühlen für 10
15 minuten und dann auch bei 180 grad
ober unterhitze für zehn bis zwölf
minuten backen ich lasse dann
vollständig auskühlen und nehmen dann
wie gesagt noch meine kuvertüre setzte
in der mikrowelle einfach ja schmelzen
und dann die spitzen nochmal rein tunken
[Musik]
so ich nehme jetzt hier nochmal ein
drittel und wert darauf sind klingel
machen weil ich finde auf einem
plätzchen teller muss auf jeden fall was
mit zimt dabei sein und da machen wir
einfach folgendes wir werden das jetzt
kurz geschmeidig kneten also wirklich so
kurz wie möglich
dann werde ich aus rollen auf
frischhaltefolie mit butter bestreichen
und mit zimt zucker bestreuen
[Musik]
der grund warum wir das direkt auf der
folie ausgebreitet haben es einfach der
dass man es viel einfacher auf rollen
kann und jetzt werde ich einfach hier
drin noch mal richtig gut verschließen
dann kommt das bei mir ins gefrierfach
für zehn minuten ihr könnt aber auch für
20 oder 30 minuten in den kühlschrank
legen dann einfach scheiben runter
schneiden und ab aufs backblech damit
[Musik]
die bauzeit für die zim kriege beträgt
ungefähr elf bis zwölf minuten ist
natürlich immer ein auge drauf haben bei
gleicher temperatur übrigens 180 grad
ober unterhitze achtet darauf dass sie
nicht zu dunkel werden dann werden sie
halt trocken
[Musik]
und ich mach jetzt hier weiter mit der
zweiten platte sozusagen und dann nehme
ich mir jetzt gleich erstmal gut die
hälfte will schon fast sagen und werde
mir den kakao brauen einfärben das heißt
ich nehm bacau das ist der stark
endgültiger sinnig der trinkaus und da
könnt ihr dann auch noch immer ein
bisschen milch dazugeben weil der ist
halt sehr trocken und verbindet sich
besser wenn ihr dann schlückchen weil
sie noch ein bisschen mehr dazu gibt
[Musik]
und schon haben wir einen kakao teil
davon brauche ich jetzt nicht alles also
von diesem cacau tag ging ich mir auch
so ungefähr ein drittel weg den rest
baur ich gleich dann könnte ich mir den
hellen vanille tag nochmal kurz
geschmeidig und zeigt euch dann wie ihr
solche worlds macht also einfach nur
hübsche kekse da müsste einfach ganz
viele kugeln rollen und dann gibt es da
einfach eine ganz einfache technik wie
er das hinbekommt
[Musik]
die cookies wandern jetzt bei 180 grad
ober unterhitze für circa 15 minuten in
den backofen die brauchen wir auch keine
kühe zeit vorher das ist alles kein
problem ich habe sie vorher noch so ein
bisschen flach angedrückt
[Musik]
ich mache jetzt weiter mit leckeren
pistazien keksen ich wollte auch gerne
das auf dem teller so ein bisschen
buntes drauf ist wir haben jetzt gelb
wir haben brown habe einfach nur beige
oder beziehungsweise weist und was grün
ist darf nicht fehlen in dem ich jetzt
meine pistazien das ist übrigens die aus
dem shop aus gaziantep verlinke euch
alles unten in der box die gebe ich
jetzt in meinen mixa falls sie seien
mixa nicht habt einfach mit einem
nudelholz in gefrierbeutel draufhauen
bis es richtig schön klein wird oder
richtig fein hacken das funktioniert
auch hauptsache sie wenn klein
[Musik]
also meine aussage mit dem gefrierbeutel
ziehe ich auf jeden fall zurück denn die
sollten schon sehr fein sein adaption
der ofen ich wollte nur kurz die
pistazien mit marzipan und ein bisschen
puderzucker verkneten wohl aber kurz die
kekse von vorhin raus und dann geht's
weiter
die sind
fertig wenn
du willst dich doch den weg um ahmed
nehmen 3
das ist alles das wird alles länger
dauern lassen
okay da mache ich jetzt weiter also für
zucker darf nicht fehlen lässt sich auch
ein bisschen besser verkneten verknetet
so lange bis ihr quasi grünen marzipan
nein grünen bist a 10 marzipan habt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich mir aus hellem steigt
wieder das ist wieder ich habe mir
diesmal also rechteckig ein bisschen das
ganze ausgerollt aber wieder unter der
frischhaltefolie das heißt wir wollen
gleich wieder auf wie bei den zimt
städtchen die habe ich jetzt genannt ich
weiß es gar nicht mehr auf jeden fall
müsst euch nicht so viel mühe geben denn
am ende wird sowieso hübsch und man
sieht gar nicht wie ihr das ausgerollt
hab ich nehme jetzt hier mein marzipan
strang werden doch noch ein bisschen
dünner rollen dann gebe ich den in die
mitte soll das ganze auf und dann werde
ich noch mal für zehn minuten ins
gefrierfach geben weil ich finde man
kann es doch einfach besser
durchschneiden
[Musik]
die pistazien kekse brauchen jetzt
ebenfalls bei 180 grad ober und
unterhitze circa 15 minuten sondern sich
ganz auf die dicke an da müsste oder
dürfte kann halt immer mal wieder
kontrollieren
ich mache jetzt weiter mit unseren
letzten plätzchen ich habe hier ja noch
cacau teig und das werden man die
plätzchen da habe ich jetzt hier gemacht
man denn die könnte jetzt ganz einfach
ein arbeiten anschließend werde ich den
teig auf der arbeitsfläche ausrollen und
dann in ganz grobe stückchen schneiden
mandeln nochmal on top geben da könnte
ja gehobelte nehmen oder gestiftete und
dann kommen sie auch aufs backblech und
werden bei gleicher temperatur so acht
bis zehn minuten gebacken also sie sind
schon bei mir sehr dünn aber wie gesagt
bei der bei den bucks zeiten immer ein
auge drauf haben manchmal brauchen sie
auch eine minute länger
[Musik]
also auf dem teller weise ist nicht aber
insgesamt habe ich 250 tags darauf
an wie viel mehr ich gebraucht hat
fast die hälfte ist also ein aus einem
kilo mehl bekommt jetzt nach dem rezept
echt 250 kekse damit könnt ihr so viele
familien beschenken oder selbst
vernaschen größeres von europa schocken
wird diese ganze tisch voll ist ja
wasser da gibt's auch noch
verschiedenste kekse also nur seinen
stab der 1 ich glaube mir den abend am 1
auf einer hochzeit ist okay mit schoko
stage lustig und ich bin voll der
zitronen fällen also selbst detail ist
heftig zeit noch nicht so dass er hat
also so schwer
traktoren jetzt eigentlich direkt am
mikrofon so alles mehr machen müssen
wo ich meine da war
hier
so toll und die mordenden dankeschön so
ich mit sagen mach das gerne macht es
unbedingt sogar nach ohne ich freue mich
über eure fotos auf instagram richtig
konnten abschließen jetzt ein café paar
kekse und darm erklärt weil hansa fans
zwar 12 uhr morgens bei der ernte ist
auf jeden fall gerettet
der nächste tag also ich wünsche euch
viel spaß und nachmachen und wir sehen
uns dann beim nächsten oder selbst
[Musik]